just one day after pro football star
deshawn watson was suspended for six
games to start the new season the nfl is
punishing one of its teams for violating
the integrity of the game policy a
six-month investigation found the miami
dolphins violated tampering rules
speaking with superstar tom brady and an
agent for coach sean payton while they
were under contract with other teams nfl
commissioner roger goodell called the
findings unprecedented this
investigation stems from a lawsuit filed
by former dolphins head coach brian
flores who claims that he was pressured
to lose games
for the miami dolphins players it's
business as usual on the practice field
but behind the scenes the nfl unleashed
a bombshell punishment on the team for
major tampering violations the dolphins
will forfeit their first round pick next
year and the third round pick in 2024
owner stephen ross will be suspended
until after week six of the season
meaning he cannot enter the team
headquarters and he'll pay a 1.5 million
dollar fine you don't normally see a
commissioner come out in a disciplinary
process like that and go after an owner
the way that he did conor orr a staff
writer for sports illustrated says on
the heels of monday's six-game
suspension of cleveland browns
quarterback deshaun watson for
allegations of sexual misconduct the nfl
was put in a unique position the nfl had
wanted to suspend watson for at least a
year but an independent judge settled on
six games they were put in a corner in
terms of
they've never punished owners as
significantly as they were trying to
punish deshaun watson maybe this is why
you're seeing such a change in tone from
goodell and maybe this is why you're
seeing the league be a little less
afraid today in terms of being critical
about other owners the investigation by
the league found the dolphins tried to
recruit tom brady on multiple occasions
while he was under contract with other
teams the team also made contact with an
agent for head coach sean payton while
he was with the saints ross said on the
tampering allegations i strongly
disagree with the conclusions and the
punishment however i will accept the
outcome in the lawsuit that initiated
the investigation former dolphins head
coach brian flores noted the team's
contact with a prominent quarterback and
he also claimed ross offered him 100
thousand dollars for each game he lost
in 2019 so the team could get better
draft picks we spoke to flores in
february after he sued the league this
game you know changed my life uh so to
attack the integrity of the game that's
that's what i felt was happening in that
instance and
i wouldn't stand for it and that was
dolphin's owner steven ross yes
yes but the league's investigation found
the dolphins did not intentionally lose
games in 2019 nor did anyone at the club
including mr ross instruct coach flores
to do so but it notes ross did express
his belief that the team's draft
position should take priority over the
team's win loss record in a statement
nfl commissioner roger goodell said even
if made in jest and not intended to be
taken seriously comments suggesting that
draft position is more important than
winning can be misunderstood ross says
the league cleared the team of flores
allegations and flores said in a
statement i am disappointed to learn
that the investigation minimized mr
ross's offers and pressure to tank games
one note about stephen ross's suspension
it's the same number of games as desean
watson's punishment for allegations of
sexual assault the nfl still can appeal
the arbitrator's decision on watson's
suspension but it must do so by tomorrow
and you wonder i mean ross is 82
billionaire how much of an impact that
really has on him but as a former player
how much of an impact does this have on
the actual team
you know it's it's funny to say but it's
the reality when things happen outside
of the facility and by outside i mean
upstairs above you we call the guys in
the suits coaches owners gm's
we can turn a blind eye if it's not
directly impacting the x's and o's the
play of the quarterback how we operate
on the practice field end on game day
not much
but when they start dealing with issues
let's just say the browns for example
that's a completely different situation
yeah because you're talking about a man
and some serious allegations that could
offend a teammate and then you have to
sit in that locker room with an
individual so now it's up to me as a
teammate to understand who deshawn
watson is do you accept him as a
teammate do you accept what he did or
did not do so they're two separate
situations miami dolphins and the
cleveland browns right yeah